[Music]
please welcome the very funny john door
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
let's get right to the jokes uh this is
true last week i nearly heard a habitat
heart a heart attack oh my god sorry uh
i nearly had a heart i heart oh my god
um last week i heard a heart had a heart
uh last week i got my heart on caught in
a hammock there we go
oh
i couldn't get it out
and i couldn't get it out but that's
fine
because whenever you're faced with a
life-or-death situation like that it
forces you to look back on life you get
nostalgic but that can be dangerous
because sure we have fond memories that
fill us with joy
but i also have regrets
like when i was 13
i farted in a mayonnaise jar
and i recapped it
and i put it in the refrigerator
and soon afterwards i watched my
grandmother
assemble a ham cheese and mayonnaise
sandwich
and then i watched her eat it
but i also have regrets
things i wish i didn't do
don't clap it's not that funny
uh
but one regret i do have is uh i bought
my nephew a kite for christmas yeah i
will never ever buy another child a kite
for christmas because kites are like
smoke signals to pedophiles all right
they know what's on the other end of the
string okay
it's called dinner well i don't know if
they're eating the children it doesn't
matter
i gotta look that up
but what's interesting is i sent my
friend adam uh a text and then my friend
adam texted me back and the text that
adam wrote me read
call me in ten minutes or else i'm
having a shower
yeah adam doesn't really know how to
threaten people if you think about it i
mean think about that you're going to
have to thrive
from you guys you're going to move yeah
you're going to because uh move you to
the back just up here yeah and if you
don't know are you together i don't know
if i should start again oh okay um
excuse me we're going to move this group
excuse me yep hi sorry
what are you doing oh i'm just moving
some people trying to arrange the crowd
for the segment okay yeah well
i'm trying to work here so oh me too so
we have a lot in common i guess
all right no i i don't think you
understand like i think what i'm doing
is a little bit more important than what
you're doing right now all right is it
okay yeah a pedophile joke i'm trying to
move them so that i can
have it better
what i'm doing is actually i think do
you think this is easy i think it's very
easy do you think what i'm doing you
think this is easy you think this is
guys guys guys
guys
guys you're both being incredibly
unprofessional yeah and i don't even
think we have ushers yeah we don't that
is
i mean for god's sake show some maturity
oh i'm sorry
do you think this is easy
[Applause]
oh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
sarah chuck
[Music]
hey sarah are you promoting anything uh
yes
actually i am oh that's
okay wow
ladies and gentlemen huh i've been
hosting a late night show for 20 years
now and i think i have to say john dore
is the best comic i have ever seen round
of applause
john doerr is a genius i don't know why
john doerr isn't the host of conan well
that's our show i want to thank my guest
john
doerr amanda